foreign
good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is scp-4246
containment class esoteric secondary
class archon disruption class Amita and
risk class caution
special containment procedures
complete containment of scp-4246
phenomena is not presently feasible
although it has been hypothesized that
efforts to impede or terminate the
anomaly may result in events detrimental
to the preservation of normalcy a
disinformation campaign is to be
maintained to actively discredit the
legitimacy of claims made by
scp-4246-1 and their supporters such
allegations are to be dismissed as works
of fiction the product of mental illness
or religious delusion communities and
Cults comprised of
scp-4246-1 and non-anomalous Associates
are to be closely monitored
it is of the utmost importance that
suspected
scp-4246-1 type B are secured and
contained as soon as possible due to
their ability to gain preternatural
knowledge of the foundation and its
inner workings instances of
scp-4246-1 type B are to be captured and
contained within psi-resistant humanoid
containment cells
scp-4246-1 type B must be physically
restrained for their own safety when
triangulating the location or in close
proximity to
scp-4246 transmitters such as
scp-4246 2 and 3. the existence of
scp-4246 2 and 3 along with their
creators must be hidden from the public
by any means necessary in the case of
scp-4246-3 provisional containment area
48 has been constructed and must be
maintained members of mobile task force
Epsilon 19 the psych ward are the only
individuals allowed within SCP 4246 3
unless authorized by site director
description
scp-4246 primarily manifests as a morbid
psychological condition involving dreams
hallucinations delusions and fixations
of a singular relation to the ocean and
its contents individuals afflicted by
scp-4246 are classified as
scp-4246-1 and displays significant
behavioral changes including the
development of abnormal neuropathologies
most
scp-4246-1 will eventually come to
interpret their anomalous experiences as
spiritual visions conveying some manner
of Revelation or esoteric knowledge
ultimately leading to the creation of
Cults and related organizations
the most immediate distinction that
separates
scp-4246 from unrelated experiences is
the inexplicable commonality between
episodes and reactions frequently
reported elements include
visions of sprawling and colossal cities
Beneath the Sea the windowless
structures display non-euclidean
architecture and are composed of a
material described as smooth seamless
glassy and black
Visions involving Gardens of coral
displaying Indescribable colors
presumably outside the human visual
Spectrum
an uncontrollable psychological urge to
immerse themselves in seawater often to
the point of self-endangerment
hallucinations involving symbols of
Unknown Origin or context usually
manifesting as short rapid flashes that
leave fleeting imprints upon an
individual's paracentral Vision these
Visions have been known to trigger
dizziness vertigo post-traumatic stress
psychosis Mania and or depression
homicidal or thoughts and behavior and
the development of new hallucinations
Afflicted individuals have been known to
kill family and friends in an effort to
save them from an ill-defined but
nevertheless impending cataclysm reports
of Sensations similar to those described
by sufferers of phantom pain and body
Integrity disorder but manifesting as
healthy people with their bodies intact
feeling as though they are missing limbs
that otherwise never existed Afflicted
individuals understand that this feeling
is illogical and that the human body
normally has four limbs but continue to
experience these Sensations regardless
of acceptance individuals have described
incidents of phantom pain registering up
to 12 meters away from their body as if
these non-existent appendages were
significantly longer than their actual
limbs there exist several cases of
acutely Afflicted individuals removing
the limbs of others and attempting to
graft them onto their own body with
fatal results
the majority of
scp-4246-1 will eventually
self-terminate by drowning in the ocean
while all appear to suffer the
compulsion to do so a minority are able
to resist the urge
scp-4246-1 are divided into type A type
B and type c variants type A individuals
are the most common and generally
display one or more of the previously
noted symptoms it is unknown how many
scp-4246-1 type A exist but their
reaction to
scp-4246 is generally self-contained and
easily countered by the propagation of
disinformation
acutely affected individuals exhibit
extra sensory perception or ESP such as
the ability to identify information
hidden from normal senses as well as
Predator natural knowledge of a
subject's thoughts and memories these
individuals have been classified as
scp-4246-1 type B and following Decades
of research have been determined to be
psi-positive
non-psychokinetic passive receivers
unwillingly absorbing information via
ESP but unable to actively transmit it
information regarding
scp-4246-1 type-c requires level 4
clearance or authorization by project
awakened dreamer director Dr Joan
Henrick
the earliest known effort to catalog and
explain the scp-4246 phenomena was by
English occultist Joseph Adler
1833-1921 leader of the Hermetic order
of universal wisdom an organization
devoted to the study and practice of the
occult metaphysics and paranormal
activities during the late 19th and
early 20th centuries in his book The
drowned kingdoms or the Eternal dreams
of the firstborn Adler discusses his
lifelong visions and astral exploration
of the ruins of a long-forgotten race
which he refers to as the firstborn
unlike other claims involving lost
worlds and civilizations a popular
concept at the time Adler's work
includes extensive interviews with
others so-called dreamers
scp-4246-1 type a lending evidence to an
anomalous phenomenon and makes accurate
scientific conclusions describing
Concepts such as plate tectonics
Evolution mimetics and physics
on October 29 1920 Adler and nine of his
followers attempted Mass astral
projection in the hopes of learning more
about the firstborn the attempt resulted
in three deaths from acute myocardial
infarction commonly known as a heart
attack two from intracranial hemorrhage
non-traumatic and four by
self-termination various methods Adler
himself ultimately survived but had been
rendered permanently blind
interview log Joseph Adler o1 14 1921
viewer Dr Franz Schroeder Alias Dr White
forward
an interview with Joseph Adler leader of
the Hermetic order of universal wisdom
interview takes place at Broadmoor
Hospital in Berkshire England
despite the subject's sickly demeanor
around lack of sight he is alert and
displays an abnormal level of awareness
of his surroundings
playing log now
hello Mr Adler
my name is Dr White
how do you fare today
you are not from here
I was recently transferred from do not
lie Mr Schroeder your arrival was
foretold in the tendulums
hey I was not made aware of your
anomalous capabilities
you are not what I expected
your dossi suggested a lunatic
I assure you Mr Schroeder that that I am
the epitome of Sanity yes a man so
consumed by Madness that he tore out his
own eyes
tell me Mr Abba how can one commits such
an act of self-destruction and still
claim sanity
I had no choice
how knowledgeable are you regarding the
deep sea
it isn't my area of expertise I don't
see how that has any reaction has always
fascinated me
in dreams since youth I plumbed the
depths of the pleiadic Abyss
I beheld with all the unforgotten
edifices of the Elder race
we fear that there can cause embrace
brace our undulating vastness
despite this fear
she inspires within our hearts a
singular curiosity
one day man will know that world
do you know what the deaths do to the
human body
you drown one could drown in a cup of
water
no
the deep is different
the pressure crosses your organs and
shatters your bones this is why
submersibles must be built strong
in time a man will create something
capable of enduring the abyss
the mind is not so different from such a
vessel as it can only dive so deeper
before
this
I looked too far
beheld that which no man should ever see
Beyond conception Beyond perception
I looked too far and something
something did not appreciate my gaze
compared to man the firstborn were his
gods
if they could not stop it what chance do
we have
end log
closing statement
the subject appears to be a true
telepath presumably a Type 3 Psy
positive or higher
recommend a Maynard sidwick test to
ensure a comprehensive diagnosis
operatives arrived at Broadmoor Hospital
the next day intending on taking Joseph
Adler into Foundation custody he was
discovered unresponsive in his room and
was later declared deceased the body was
delivered to humanoid containment site
744 where it would undergo autopsy
Adler's cause of death was indeterminate
but it was thought at the time to be the
result of untreated pneumonia aggravated
by recent trauma
among Adler's belongings was an
unfinished draft of a map depicting an
unknown location it was initially
believed that the partially depicted
land mass was an Uncharted Island as the
apparent Coastline failed to coincide
with any known location and the etching
itself offered no sense of scale all
efforts to find this island failed and
the map was dismissed as irrelevant
until 1956.
instances of
scp-4246-1 type A would continue to be
tracked and observed while
scp-4246-1 type B individuals were
secured as per special containment
procedures at humanoid containment site
744 there would be no change in the
foundation's understanding of scp-4246
phenomena until 1954 when Dr Charles
Baker noticed certain patterns in the
main art sidwick test results of
scp-4246-1b leading him to hypothesize
that
scp-4246 influenced individuals are not
true SCI positive individuals and that
they are merely receiving information
sent and or displaced by an outside
force testing this hypothesis required
the creation of a new method of PSI
assessment one taking the timing of
failure and success into account with
the presentation of new information
it was discovered that
scp-4246-1 type B require a subject
relatively nearby to read suggesting
that the displaced information decayed
the further it moved from its original
Source or that it was dependent on the
number of sources or mines not distance
traveled in such case
scp-4246-1 type B on opposite ends of
the world would be able to read each
other's minds clearly after the passing
of nscp 4246 wave as long as there were
no other Minds to dilute this
information
during interviews of type B instances a
significant difference arose between
cases where interviewers knew questions
or answers in advance and cases where
interviewers were not aware of questions
or answers before the interview in the
former cases
scp-4246-1 type B were able to ascertain
any information held by the interviewer
however in the latter there would be a
delay of 1 to 12 seconds with enough
interviews occurring simultaneously
researchers were able to conclude that
the scp-4246 phenomena required
approximately 12 seconds to reach site
744 from its point of origin this
suggests that Dr Baker's hypothesis was
correct and that scp-4246 is likely a
frequency of unknown wavelength
significantly slower than
electromagnetic radiation if its Origins
are unimpeded and terrestrial but potent
enough to cause information displacement
or amplification receivable to varying
degrees by an unknown number of
individuals
this is a statement from Dr Charles
Baker
scp-4246 originating from X and
traveling at the speed of Y will reach
site 744 and approximately 12 seconds I
hypothesize that this could be solved by
simply transferring
scp-4246-1 type B to a number of sites
at different parts of the world and
conducting the experiment again
hypothetically identifying a new maximum
delay of ignorance could help
triangulate the point of origin for the
scp-4246 phenomena
the experiment was once again concluded
as described but the results revealed an
unforeseen problem the initial
hypothesis was predicated on the
supposition that scp-4246 had a single
point of origin but the results
ultimately suggest that
scp-4246 is being transmitted from
multiple points greatly complicating our
search
however one important detail was gleaned
from this data the delay of ignorance
dramatically decreased with proximity to
the ocean Inland seas and freshwater
bodies displayed no such influence for
reasons unknown the Atlantic Ocean
resulted in a relatively longer delay
approximately eight seconds compared to
the Pacific Ocean which had the shortest
delay approximately two seconds
suffice it to say the source of scp-4246
is in the sea
coinciding with the efforts of Dr Baker
was Research into the symptomatic
similarities between
scp-4246-1 individuals a study overseen
by Dr Stefan Gartner noticed that
certain not previously described habits
often manifested among the more
artistically disposed
scp-4246-1 these included depictions
resembling The partially drafted map of
Joseph Adler an estimated 12 000
distinct images were compared and
combined along with Adler's original
draft creating a complete map displaying
intricate cities and geographical
features despite its incredible detail
approximately 20 percent of the map was
empty space primarily in the form of a
large c-shaped mass left of center the
amount of detail depicted in regions
initially hypothesized is water led many
to hypothesize that Adler's map depicted
a lake rather than an island
in 1956 when the foundation began to
accept plate tectonic theory researchers
of the scp-4246 phenomena came to the
realization that all previous
interpretations of the complete Adler
map were wrong and that the image's
empty space depicted the supercontinent
of Pangea which had existed during the
late Paleozoic and early Mesozoic eras
in turn the detailed portion of the map
intended to depict the ocean floor
complete with the unexpected yet
undeniable markings of civilization
a statement by Dr Stephan Gartner
one by one like pieces of a puzzle the
Adler map was created after months of
tedious craft at first we knew not what
to think the complete image may as well
have been some intangible Dreamscape a
born of the collective subconscious of
scp-4246-1 but scientific consensus
became a quick and integral Ally the
conclusions of plate tectonics solving a
puzzle we would have otherwise struggled
with for decades
as part of my research on
scp-4246-1 I introduced a copy of the
map into my weekly interviews and asked
if they recognized it their reactions
ranged from suffocating dread to
excitement bordering on euphoria
this is the world that haunts their
dreams
but why
the Adler map was divided into tectonic
plates and rearranged to match the
placement of continents in the present
era using the data from Dr Baker's delay
of ignorance experiments the foundation
was able to estimate the most probable
locations for scp-4246 transmitters
these transmitters have been classified
as
scp-4246 II
scp-4246 2A Pacific Ocean Polynesia
an instance of
scp-4246-2 was traced 26 degrees south
112 degrees west in the Pacific Ocean
West of Easter Island on July 15 1959
the FSS ammonite departed from Naval
operations site 67 in Hawaii with the
objective of locating this potential
scp-4246 II as the vessel neared its
destination a number of submariners
complained of headache nausea and
hallucination it was around this time
that radar began to pick up a large
mobile object following the FSS ammonite
and a stalking distance believing in
another submarine the FSS ammonite
pinged the object but received no
response the unidentified aquatic object
reportedly disappeared from radar only
to reappear hours later despite the
presence of this unknown object and the
deteriorating mental status of the crew
the FSS ammonite was ordered to continue
with its mission
radar began to pick up abnormalities on
the sea floor searchlights swept through
the water and the FSS ammonite reported
what appeared to be a sprawling
megalithic City the black ruins
reflected no light and displayed
non-euclidean architecture resembling
that of no terrestrial civilization
mere minutes after its Discovery the
crew of the FSS ammonite erupted an
apparent Mutiny The Vessel was ordered
to resurface but its ballast tanks were
damaged possibly sabotaged and unable to
repressurize radio communication
remained online but suffered significant
interference and while the FSS ammonite
was able to communicate with command
messages from command could not be
received from FSS ammonite
a rescue mission was considered
infeasible at the time the vessel's
radio remained active revealing how the
crew succumbed to delirium followed by
Bloodshed recorded below is the final
message received from the FSS ammonite
the rest are dead only I remain while
they fought like fools I saved my
strength and abided my time the last man
left standing was near death when I
approached he has joined the others now
the gods speak to me
this isn't a tragedy it's Fate The
Guardian was made to protect their
secret
I've painted myself in the blood of the
Fallen I and I alone am worthy
the tendrils coil around my heart this
this is their love
please
embrace me
despite knowledge of its coordinates at
the time of its disappearance the
wreckage of the FSS ammonite was never
found in 1977 remotely operated
underwater Vehicles were deployed to the
region of the sea floor where
scp-42462a was first encountered no
evidence for the ruins was found but the
location remains classified as
scp-4246-2a as it remains a strong
transmitter of scp-4246 regardless of
its lack of physical evidence
scp-4246-1 type B brought to this
location became excitable and expressed
the following
identification number
scp-4246-1 type B 36 notable quotations
the tides are calling in my name my soul
is below entangled among the tendrils
cast me down and let the undertow
complete me
notes subject became incoherent and
spent the rest of their time struggling
to free themselves from their strengths
identification number
scp-4246-1 type B number 40. notable
quotations they are still dreaming even
after all this time they dream of things
of incomprehensible profundity we are so
small weak and worthless Our Miss
begotten race does not deserve this
world it is a cosmic joke that we even
came this far
notes subject became despondent
identification number
scp-4246-1 type B number 40. notable
quotations none notes subjects screamed
continuously until removed from the area
all relevant type B and Foundation
Personnel displayed shared life memories
following their removal from
scp-42462a Afflicted individuals were
administered amnestics to minimize the
effect
scp-4246 2B Pacific Ocean Micronesia
a second
scp-4246-2 was traced six degrees north
157 degrees east south west of the
micronesian island of Pompeii the
anomaly was discovered during a November
1961 investigation into reports of
occult activity among the ruins of Nan
madal the island was under U.S
Administration following World War II
but reports were made by Japanese
occupiers including reports of unusual
behavior associated with scp-4246
phenomena
locals directed Foundation operatives to
the ruins claiming that it had been
overrun by the drowned a cult worshiping
these so-called old gods Foundation
operatives confronted the cult at Nam at
all who were found to be non-hostile and
at least somewhat Cooperative the
majority were Native Islanders but
American and Japanese Nationals were
discovered living among them as well
though generally peaceful the community
routinely practiced Human Sacrifice
though selected for sacrifice appear
more than willing to die for their faith
through diplomacy Foundation operatives
were allowed to observe the ritual the
drowned traveled by canoe to their
chosen place of sacrifice which has
since been identified as an scp-4246
transmitter and classified as
scp-4246-2b the offering a young poloan
woman appeared joyous as others tied
heavy stones to her limbs those around
her chanted and anointed her in oil
before consigning her to the Sea the
drowned did not perceive their actions
as lethal and instead believed that they
had merely facilitated her rebirth or
some manner of metamorphosis they
insisted that she would live on for
eternity among the gods and their Coral
palaces much like
scp-42462a the foundation found no
physical evidence to explain
scp-4246-2-b's transmission both the
drowned and
scp-4246-1 type B claimed there were
cities on the sea floor but no evidence
was found to support this
the drowned disappeared in 1963. bodies
would occasionally wash ashore in the
following months the entire Community is
believed to have committed Master by
drowning
While most comments were unintelligible
Some
scp-4246-1 Type B expressed the
following potentially meaningful
statements
identification number
scp-4246-1 type B number 27.
notable quotations what you seek is here
but anchored elsewhere don't let reality
deceive you the hungry Earth devours but
the firstborn will never truly die they
exist outside the cycle you've had that
dream again haven't you Dr Gardner you
knew the risks and sent them anyway
remember
notes subject began to discuss highly
sensitive information Psy Inhibitors
Amplified in response
identification number
scp-4246-1 type B number 36. notable
quotations they rise and Rise you took
them you butchers I still feel them
where are they give them back make me
whole
notes subject trembled and wept
uncontrollably
identification number
scp-4246-1 type B number 41. notable
quotations the sunken city awaits all is
black where there once was light they
are gods that were and shall be again
soon everyone will see everyone will
notes subject fell into a catatonic
state but ultimately recovered three
days later
scp-4246 2C Arctic Ocean
the foundation had already encountered
evidence for
scp-42462c in October 1918 following
reports of an abandoned Village
containing occult paraphernalia on the
island part of the Pharaoh Islands
Foundation agents discovered that the
missing inhabitants were members of the
church of Saint Jonah a cult outwardly
presenting itself as a Protestant
Christian sect among the recovered
non-anomalous artifacts was a 45
kilogram Stone statue depicting a
vaguely anthropoid entity with the
exaggerated abdomen hips and breasts of
an obese and or pregnant human female
the head of an anglerfish the protruding
spines of an echinoderm and appendages
resembling serpents or tentacles
a journal belonging to Pastor Broder
sigur darson the apparent founder and
leader of the church of Saint Jonah was
discovered within an abandoned Chapel at
The Villages Center several excerpts of
node are included in the following
collapsible translated to English from
their original Danish
[Music]
13th of September 1904.
the churches sent me to this desolate
Island to replace a pastor who's been
deceased for decades
faith it seems has little place in this
Village perhaps the Heathen Spirit of
our ancestors lingers more strongly
among such isolation
I should not complain for the church in
its Mercy has allowed me a chance to
redeem myself perhaps for once the
rumors and accusations of my past won't
follow
the 5th of October 1904. my congregation
is small and primarily comprised of the
wives and children of fishermen to
protect their husbands they ask for the
blessings of Jonah but never our Lord
and savior
how easy it is for the veneration of
saints to devolve into idolatry
the venara disagreeable lot who take to
drink the moment they set foot on dry
land
these drunkards view my status as an
unmarried man with suspicion and have
accused me of fornicating with their
wives or the crime of sodomy these fools
have no trouble hurling such
contradictions
Lord grant me patience
the 22nd of December 1904. the call is
stronger here I had begged the church to
send me somewhere Inland for this very
reason like burning or silkeborg
anywhere but the islands
it was not a seizure but that is how
they Justified my freedom just an
accident unavoidable
but it wasn't I remember it all with
such Clarity it should have been a
simple baptism the way the infant
gargled and choked
I held her down let our lungs fill with
holy water until the bubble ceased her
eyes
I hear the call of the deep
our Lord protect me
the 10th of January 1905.
the abyss speaks to me of betrayal and
murderous plot Captain absalon's wife is
pregnant but he knows that The Unborn
Child cannot be his yes it has shown me
his secret shame and the guilt of dagger
a supposed friend for whom he Bears no
suspicion
the captain is not an intelligent
creature he is a drunken Beast of rage
and humiliation and his ale sickened
mind has convinced him that I am the
true father
he and his brothers plot their Revenge
seeking my demise
but I will not act
not yet
let them come
I am ready
the 22nd of February 1905.
the conspirators breached my sanctum
last night I told them the truth and
offered them a chance to walk away
they made their choice now that entrails
decorate the village it never had to
come to this I stood in the Town Center
baptized by the blood of criminals and
awaited the dawn
when the rest awoke they were witness to
my glory
tarot will ensure their obedience
the abyss Whispers its secrets and I am
its prophet
the Christ God is dead
the Deep gods are eternal
the true faith is triumphant the last of
the non-believers have been purged bound
and thrown on a scarier tab this
sacrifice will appease the Deep Gods but
only for so long preparations must be
made to ensure a steady and sustainable
harvest in the future
the gods have seen fit to bless my body
with renewed Vigor and singular
carnality in my dreams I hunt for pearls
among the seafoam and awaken to passions
that at once caused me such shame
many women who are rendered widowed by
The Purge and I have claimed them as my
Brides
this received no protest indeed they
felt honored
due to a lack of corroborating evidence
the events surrounding the church of
Saint Jonah were classified as a
possible extra normal incident the case
was reported in 1964 due to its notable
similarities to scp-4246 related
phenomena though the village itself had
been raised as per pre-1948 protocol
scp-4246-1 type B were delivered to its
former site and able to detect a strong
scp-4246 frequency originating from the
distant North the signal was tracked to
87 degrees North 170 degrees east in the
Arctic Ocean like
scp-4246 2A and 2B
scp-4246 2C lacked any apparent physical
source for its transmission
shipwrecks litter this region of the sea
floor and include fishing or whaling
vessels canoes and Norse longships how
they were able to reach so far within
the Arctic Circle despite the ice and
lethal cold remains unknown it is
presumed that all those who traveled to
this site had no intention of surviving
the journey
though most were incoherent Some
scp-4246-1 Type B brought to this
location expressed the following
identification number
scp-4246-1 type B number 19.
notable quotations it is the final pin
to hold it
little interest in land Empires with the
north they made themselves whole the
dream belonged to everyone
note subject appeared particularly lucid
identification number
scp-4246-1 type B number 25.
notable quotations drown yourself and
complete the circle the sea will remake
you your lungs will learn to take in
water do it do it we must all drown so
that they might return
notes subject was found unresponsive
after testing it ended they had
apparently bitten off their own tongue
and suffocated themselves through the
inhalation of blood
identification number
scp-4246-1 type B number 40. notable
quotations this is but an echo we are
far from the true Source they buried
their heart in ice it is black and cold
and the heart longs for light
notes subject fell into a depressive
state
an additional 18
scp-4246-2 would be discovered bringing
their total number to 21. these
transmitters do not appear to have any
obvious pattern or advantages to their
current geographical location however
when superimposed over a map of this
supercontinent Pangea as it existed 300
million years ago
scp-4246-2 form a pattern that maximizes
reach over ocean distances ultimately
implying some manner of intelligent
design behind the creation of the
scp-4246 anomaly Dr Joan Henrik would
propose a solution to lingering
questions surrounding scp-4246 II
inspired by a comment made by
scp-4246-1 type B number 27. she
hypothesized that the creators of
scp-4246 had purposefully hidden the
presence of scp-4246 II through
dimensional manipulation revisiting
these locations CAD counters would
register at a difference of 60 Humes in
relation to the surrounding environment
revealing a high degree of dimensional
instability Dr Henrik would further
hypothesize that
scp-4246 II while able to receive and
transmit the scp-4246 frequency are in
fact safely tethered outside of the
Baseline iteration of Reality by some
unknown means
in an effort to properly study scp-4246
II three Scranton reality actors SRA
were modified to endure an aquatic
environment and triangularly placed
around the estimated position of
scp-4246-2a on 0807 1965 at 0.900 hours
the SRA were activated triggering the
emergence of a 600 meter tall quadruple
Helix shaped structure composed of a
smooth and seamless black material an
object remained anchored to Baseline
reality for 1 minute and 26 seconds
until the sudden obliteration of SRA
units presumably due to a dimensional
tethering overload event a second
attempt was made the following day at
0-700 hours this time with
scp-4246-2b producing similar results
though only lasting 55 seconds further
testing was prohibited as the hypothesis
had been verified and they statistically
likely loss of more Foundation assets
was deemed unacceptable it is assumed
that other
scp-4246 II are of a similar
construction as 2A and 2B
based on current evidence it is
theorized that
scp-4246 functions as a worldwide
Network what remains unanswered is its
purpose as the anomaly fails to display
any sensible goal it is possible that
scp-4246 is observable influence via
scp-4246-1 is an unintended side effect
of a far greater phenomenon if the
creation of
scp-4246-1 was indeed the goal of
scp-4246-2's creators it could have been
accomplished by simpler means for
example mimetics
during a routine scan of news media a
report of unusual seismic activity in
Antarctica was discovered relevant to
the foundation was its timing occurring
on 0807 1965 at 0.900 for an elapse of 1
minute and 26 seconds and again on 0808
1965 at 0.700 for an elapse of 55
seconds coinciding with the SRA
tethering of
scp-42462a and
scp-4246-2b the epicenter of these two
seismic events was traced to a region
presently beneath the glaciers of
Antarctica at 79 degrees south 170
degrees west operatives from mobile task
force Delta 21 the Abominable Snowman
were deployed to these coordinates
discovering a previously unrecorded
settlement at the site
it was determined that the post was
built and operated by Nazi Germany but
damaged and abandoned four reasons not
immediately discernible the presence of
a pit with a kilometer diameter and
Industrial digging equipment indicate a
large-scale excavation project later
verified by official documents after
investigating the buildings and finding
them empty mobile task force Delta 21
secured the settlement and awaited the
arrival of foundation researchers
recovered documents confirmed that
excavation efforts were part of an
ahernerbe obscura corpse operation to
recover evidence of a supposed Lost
Civilization the ahanerbe obscura Corps
had been aware of the scp-4246 anomaly
since at least the early 1930s and had
been unbeknownst to the foundation
conducting their own research into the
phenomena through the analysis of
scp-4246-1 and their Visions they were
able to deduce that this part of
Antarctica held something of
significance and were able to act on
this information before the foundation
they regarded this theoretical
civilization as some manner of Master
race though this conclusion was based
entirely on unfounded pseudoscientific
and supremacist beliefs
unfortunately most of their research
appears to have been intentionally
destroyed and only vague references to
the project have been encountered in
extant documents the amount of resources
deployed along with the apparent urgency
behind the excavation operation suggest
more than a scholarly interest in
scp-4246 it is believed that the
honorabe Obscure Corpse's ultimate goal
was to weaponize the anomaly but how
they plan to accomplish this remains
unknown
signs of conflict were found throughout
the settlement the area littered with
empty shell casings and Frozen corpses
the docks had been raised and All Ships
had been intentionally scuttled while
excavation machines had been sabotaged
and drained of diesel fuel journal
entries and Scattered memos describe
growing animosity between laborers and
their ahanerbe overseers
the excavation project had ultimately
uncovered the presence of an artificial
structure beneath the ice classified as
scp-4246-3 it displays non-euclidean
architecture and is composed of an
unusually strong and seamless material
closely resembling obsidian chemical
analysis of this material has revealed a
combination of calcium carbonate chitin
volcanic glass magnesium and iron but
efforts to replicate this material in a
lab setting have resulted in Failure
Spectrum analysis of this material has
uncovered constantly shifting symbols
designed for those capable of perceiving
light and frequencies outside the human
visible spectrum
scp-4246-3 displays an anomalous impact
on sound a whisper spoken within its
interior will reverberate and increase
in volume a mere one second utterance
can continue to resonate throughout
scp-4246-3 for just under 5 minutes
individuals who remain near the ruins
will eventually begin to hear the
thoughts of anyone in their proximity
continued exposure may result in the
development of memory overlap with one
such example involving a foundation
operative who came to believe he shared
the same wife as his partner thoughts
and memories will continue to blur until
The Afflicted individual is rendered
mentally incapable or catatonic
fortunately this can be corrected
through the application of amnestics if
treated early attempts to navigate the
site proved difficult due to the number
of steep drops and inclines along with
the extreme perceptual abnormalities
that occur within the presence of
barnacles and similarly sessile
sedentary organisms further indicates
that much of the structure if not the
entire complex was within the Ocean
prior to the late cenozoic Ice Age 33.9
million years ago there are no known
forms of protection against
scp-4246-3's anomalous influence
requiring individuals to limit their
exposure this has ultimately rendered
the vast majority of the ruins
inaccessible ground penetrating radar
has revealed the entire
scp-4246-3 complex is distributed over a
land area of about 822 kilometers
squared making it larger than New York
City
a journal was recovered from one of
scp-4246-3's various tunnels though it
lacked a signature its contents indicate
that it belonged to one of the Lost
German laborers several passages of note
include
they work us like
PSI
they say it's for the glory of the
Fatherland but that is no explanation
I always heard that the SS represented
the best of the German people
but these men I do not trust they are
strange and cast malignant looks our way
I heard the voice of Johannes but his
mouth did not move
I remembered our mother
how I Lament The sorrow our absence must
caused her
my mother is dead
and Johannes is no brother of mine
what is this
I suffer strange dreams in this place
and it seems I am not the only one
we have all seen the black City Beneath
the ice
a kingdom older than Adam
the Stones sing to us
we trespass on Holy Ground
this cannot continue
plans have been set in motion
we will show them what the gods have
shown us
the black city is alive with light
how could they not see them
they will come to understand its beauty
but we cannot return
the Fiora would taint it
nobody can leave this Frozen land alive
thank you
mobile task force Epsilon 19 the psych
ward was deployed to
scp-4246-3 in order to explore and map
its interior members of mobile task
force Epsilon 19 are resistant to
telepathic Cognito hazardous and mimetic
anomalies to achieve this they have
undergone extensive training mental
conditioning and surgical augmentation
much of
scp-4246-3's interior was found flooded
requiring the construction of dams and
drainage systems to access the majority
of areas
scp-42463's non-euclidean architecture
and labyrinthine vertical shafts have
also necessitated the use of repelling
techniques and Equipment after eight
years of exploration and the
establishment of various base camps
mobile task force Epsilon 19 completed
their survey of
scp-4246-3 the resulting network of rope
and anchors were in turn employed to
create a minimalist lift system allowing
the foundation to more efficiently move
personnel and supplies throughout the
complex as mobile task force Epsilon 19
members are the only individuals capable
of safely remaining within the complex
research was conducted indirectly via
live video faint
at the lowest level of
scp-4246-3 is a spherical chamber with
an estimated volume of 720 000 meters
cubed containing
scp-4246-4
scp-4246-4 is an organic Mass primarily
composed of neurons and glial cells the
two broad classes of cells found in the
brains of all naturally occurring
terrestrial species these cells are
alive despite lacking any obvious means
of preservation with veins transferring
Blue Blood hemocyanin throughout the
cluster indicating the existence of a
closed circulatory system
scp-4246-4 itself is submerged in water
and protected by a translucent Dome
after thorough analysis it was
determined that
scp-4246-4 was a fully functional brain
though one of unnatural size and
complexity it is currently hypothesized
that
scp-4246 is caused by the neural
oscillations or brain waves of
scp-4246-4 with scp-4246 II designed to
receive and further transmit it
throughout the world and potentially
Beyond
scp-4246-4 appears to be expanding this
brainwave across the world through a
neural network composed of
scp-4246 II strong receivers and
transmitters and the neurons of all
living things weak receivers and
transmitters but far more numerous It is
believed that
scp-4246-4 is ultimately scanning the
entire planet in a continuous cycle
gathering information for reasons still
unknown it is thus hypothesized that
scp-4246-1 through their Divergent
brains are collecting some of this
information much like a filter their
mental instability growing with Decades
of unintended contamination
the tetheian civilization hypothesis
accepted by the majority of scp-4246
researchers the tetheian civilization
hypothesis posits that a specific
civilization presumably long extinct was
responsible for the creation of scp-4246
and all related in all those objects
named for the Paleo tethus ocean which
they likely dominated It is believed
that the tethians represent a non-human
primarily aquatic civilization dating
back to at least the late Paleozoic Era
250 to 300 million years ago it is
believed that the species responsible
for scp-4246 survived the Permian
Triassic Extinction event and flourished
until the Cretaceous paleogene
Extinction event approximately 66
million years ago based on
archaeological findings the tethians
existed for at least 200 million years
and had a near incomprehensible
understanding of Science and Technology
Creations linked to this extinct
civilization show evidence of anomalous
craftsmanship their construction
seemingly Impossible by the standards of
modern human artifice it is feared that
most of their ruins are permanently lost
due to the Wilson cycle and obliterated
by subduction it appears that this race
was aware of what would happen to the
sea floor in their absence and
purposefully constructed
scp-4246-3 on a relatively safe part of
the Antarctic plate as this was not done
in the case of
scp-4246-2 and is likely that the
non-anomalous preservation of
scp-4246-3 was of singular importance
something that could not be
dimensionally anchored elsewhere as seen
with scp-4246 II the tetheian species is
unknown with no obvious signs of their
existence in the fossil records though
they left behind no images of their
people certain traits can be inferred
from the architecture of
scp-4246-3 the species was aquatic
spending the majority of their existence
on the seafloor it is probable that they
had appendages a way to meaningfully
interact and change their environment
though as their brains allowed for
telepathic communication they may have
been able to manipulate objects through
telekinetic means possibly explaining
their seamless and delicately shaped
architecture telepathy results in
certain social ramifications as well as
suspicion and deception would be
non-existent to their people
as an aquatic species it is highly
unlikely that their technology evolved
along paths comparable to humanity they
could have harnessed heat from
hydrothermal vents but they would have
never harnessed fire a fundamental and
formative development for humans the
harnessing of electricity would suffer
similar difficulties based on the
existence of
scp-4246-4 it is believed that the
tethians mastered some form of
bioengineering and biocomputation their
ability to alter reality is also firmly
established by the current state of
scp-4246-2
though still unverified it is speculated
that
scp-4246-4 was designed not only as a
living repository of knowledge but as a
secondary hive-like mind this does not
necessarily mean that the tethians
shared a single Consciousness though it
is within the realm of possibility it
may include the memories of all minds
tetheian or other that have existed
since its creation
Visions among
scp-4246-1 of vast Coral Gardens May
indicate a familiar and comforting
environment the tethians potentially
regarding coral reefs as the Cradle of
their species they did not communicate
as we do relying more heavily on
sensation than description symbols
colors and vibration work together to
directly invoke the feeling of its
creator directly transferring
information between individuals without
the problematic tool of language as
their minds were linked either through a
natural occurrence of their biology or
through the invention of scp-4246 II and
scp-4246-3 it is improbable that they
had a concept of words as we would
recognize them
their civilization flourished expanding
across the entire panthelasa super ocean
as evidenced by the far-flung locations
of
scp-4246 II despite the violent
compulsions displayed by certain
scp-4246-1 there exists no evidence to
suggest that the tethians were combative
people whatever tribalism they suffered
likely ceased to be following the
creation of
scp-4246-4 the core of their neural
network and thus their civilization
morning the following file is level four
four two four six classified
any attempt to access this file without
level four or two four six authorization
will be blocked and will lead to
immediate disciplinary action
please submit login credentials
login credentials accepted
Joseph Adler theorized the existence of
three types of people sleepers
individuals seemingly unaffected by the
scp-4246 phenomena dreamers individuals
reactive to the scp-4246 phenomena
though vague and distorted and the
awakened individuals capable of
embracing the true reality of scp-4246
the awakened were entirely hypothetical
though Adler believed himself close to
achieving this state of being Foundation
efforts to translate this supposed
Revelation electronically have failed it
is feared that human technology is
simply incompatible with the
scp-4246-4 brainwave
beginning in 1988 project awakened
dreamer was an attempt to better
understand the scp-4246 anomaly as well
as to potentially facilitate
communication with
scp-4246-4 itself through the creation
of a new variant of
scp-4246-1 classified as
scp-4246-1 type-c these awakened
subjects were genetically engineered to
act as Superior receivers of the
scp-4246 phenomena based on key
differences found between
scp-4246-1 and Baseline human brains
type c have a 250 percent Mass increase
of the pineal gland a 400 percent Mass
increase of the cerebral cortex and an
estimated 1 200 percent as many neurons
as the average adult human these changes
have necessitated the surgical
enlargement of the cranium to
incorporate the overall increase in
brain mass type c individuals also
receive a steady supply of perception
altering chemicals primarily NN
dimethyltryptamine on the insistence of
Dr calixto navares
these changes are not without negative
side effects
scp-4246 one type-c suffers
tetraplegia and a significantly higher
risk of epileptic seizure brain aneurysm
cerebrovascular accident and acute
myocardial infarction Advanced life
support procedures and the continuous
intravenous administration of relevant
medication are able to minimize these
life-threatening incidents
the majority of type c were created from
type B typically from those most likely
to represent an asset loss in the near
future due to self-termination or other
scp-4246 related fatalities individuals
undergoing the process have an estimated
70 percent mortality rate more
information regarding this process is
restricted on a need to note basis
unauthorized attempts to access this
information is grounds for termination
a statement from Dr Joan Henrick
I have been made aware of the ethical
concerns certain members of our
foundation hold and would prefer to
address them directly project awakened
dreamer is not cruel cold perhaps but
entirely necessary individuals who have
undergone the type C process or
Awakening do not suffer in vain nor is
there predicament significantly
different from before Bound by a
straight jacket locked in a cell and
bombarded by sound the established
security measures hardly allow for much
of a light and what kind of a life did
they live prior to containment look at
what scp-4246 has wrought how it ravages
their minds compelling them towards
self-mutilation
and even murder do not think them all as
composed and coherent as Adler he was in
aberration we cannot simply destroy
scp-4246-4 and this isn't just a matter
of General policy the anomaly has been
with us engulfing our minds long before
the dawn of math let alone mammals we
have no way of knowing how much it has
influenced us and we will not do
anything to terminate or invit the
anomaly until it is Thoroughly
understood project awakened dreamer is
our only viable option at this time if
you are unable to offer a better
solution then I suggest you stop
bothering the Ethics Committee with your
complaints this is the foundation we do
what we do because we must
scp-4246 one type c number 16 formerly
scp-4246-1 type B number 104 mourn Xena
Alexa polu was determined to be the most
capable of her kind based on Maynard's
sidwick test results subject displays a
heightened affinity for both receiving
and transmitting information via para
natural means type c number 16 was
transferred to provisional containment
area 48 constructed around the entrance
to
scp-4246-3 in Antarctica on 09 12 1992
bubble task force Epsilon 19 operatives
delivered
scp-4246-1 type c number 16 2
scp-4246-4 subject had been restricted
by mobile PSI Inhibitors and equipped
with a two-way radio interview is
conducted as PSI Inhibitors were
gradually disabled
interviewer Dr Santiago Castillo
begin log
do you read new c16
yes do it I'm going to disable the first
inhibitor please inform me whenever it
becomes too much
okay I understand
do it
I need to know the truth disables the
first inhibitor please tell me what you
experience
don't avoid any details
I see black cities
a billion unblinking eyes staring back
at me
water fills my lungs asphyxiates
the sea is full of monsters
I've seen and felt this all before
please
I am ready
show me more understood
disables the second inhibitor subject
trembles
I lost among the tendrils
and no longer struggle for air
cold and numb
but comfortably so
I hear my mother
she calls me home
she sings to me
not Psalms of words or even sound but
light and colors
so brilliant
um
horse
back to The Gardens of my ancestors
I am with my sisters
as long as we have each other we can
be safe
be silent
be simple and without light
the song grows dim
but there is Security in the Darkness
so simple and without like
or the Beast will find us subject
s Psalm is a distant memory
where are my sisters
the old Brady old plays only static
the colors remain but the meaning is
lost
we or Soul lost
our children are born small and frail
with light so terribly dim
and their children are as dark as the
void between Stars
they live short and miserable lives
oh how they've come to hate themselves
our soul has been shattered
scattered
they squabble and fight
they no longer hear this song but this
was our sacrifice to make
in the end none of us will recognize our
own
but the light cannot return
not until the time is right
please I need more I must see beyond the
end
please note I cannot guarantee your
safety Beyond this point
shall I perceive this thing has haunted
me all my life
I've done terrible unforgivable things
while under its spell
do it I need to know why I don't care
what happens
understood disables the third inhibitor
subject trembles and begins to
Hemorrhage blood from their ears nose
and eyes
are you able to continue
subject is silent but nods their head in
apparent affirmation
what are you experiencing
I see
a seal everything
but I cannot understand
the way it speaks to me
I feel it from inside
the tendrils carve a world is litany
upon my mind
what do you want from me
I draw my own children for you
I thought it was what you wanted just
tell me what to do why do you keep
calling me I'm drowning in your dream
can you see
embrace me
grant me the Peace of clarity
and my madness c-16 please listen to me
carefully
don't just receive attempt to transmit
reach out to scp-4246 for with your mind
remember what we taught you
subject screams
their volume increasing to abnormal
levels
end log
type c number 16 violently thrashed
their head side to side as a 300 plus
decibel sound wave was Unleashed
followed by a psychic backlash felt by
anyone within a 14 million kilometer
square area this anomalous reaction
lasted for approximately three minutes
and 26 seconds triggering fits and
seizures among
scp-4246-1 across the world
scp-4246-3 underwent an immediate
transformation with walls and Floors
moving as if in a liquid state the
material once again returned to a solid
after completely reshaping the
structure's interior type c16 and 12
members of mobile task force Epsilon 19
are believed to have been destroyed
during the restructuring event along
with any equipment provisional
containment area 48 suffered vibration
related damage requiring extensive
repairs above ground Personnel survived
the incident but were rendered catatonic
by the psychic backlash presumably
triggered by type c-16's attempt to
transmit to scp-4246-4
after regaining Consciousness formerly
comatose area 48 Personnel displayed
apparent knowledge of hypothetical
Science and Technology far beyond
current understanding including subjects
which haven't yet been speculated even
in the realm of Science Fiction these
include dimensional folding warp field
manipulation neural electrographics
Cosmic language simulation organic
quantum entanglement communication among
many others despite the possible
benefits of such information
experimentation in any of these fields
has yet to become feasible this has
ultimately led to depression and
frustration among impacted Personnel
resulting in a significantly increased
rate
the manner of self-termination has yet
to involve drowning indicating that an
scp-4246 related compulsion is not
responsible
Foundation operatives sent to recover
casualties discovered further changes
with
scp-4246-3 the seamless subsidian-like
material employed in its construction
had become luminescent with a number of
continuously shifting colors and
undulating symbols separated these
lights and symbols have no apparent
effect but the combination forms an
exceptionally potent Cognito Hazard
capable of triggering Rapid cerebral
hemorrhaging even among members of
mobile task force Epsilon 19 manned
exploration of
scp-4246-3 is strictly prohibited from
this point on unless directly authorized
by Dr Henrick
Foundation Network intersight com
service
3.155 Message from Dr Isaac Freeman
received playing message now
Dr Henrik no doubt the rumors of my
findings have already reached you please
know that I would never bring this to
your attention unless I was absolutely
certain of its importance I am fully
aware of the extreme skepticism with
which my research is being met it
appears that everyone has their pet
theory of who the firstborn really were
and aren't too comfortable with anything
that clashes with theirs I like everyone
here stand on the shoulders of giants
that came before Baker Gardner and the
rest opened the way they did not live to
see the truth and perhaps neither shall
we but I believe that my Discovery will
bring us closer I apologize if I sound
over dramatic but it's hard to contain
my excitement before I get into the
details consider this what if the
tethians never went extinct what if they
are hiding in plain sight but are no
longer recognizable as the advanced
species they once were Evolution isn't
some straight line towards intellectual
and physical superiority do you remember
the words of type c16 be safe be silent
be simple and without light during a
routine sweep of news media following
the 09 12 1992 incident I discovered
some fascinating correlations all
relevant data is contained in the
attachment and I urge you to pursue it
with an open mind as you'll see reports
of scp-4246 symptoms have steadily
decreased this is not to suggest that
the anomaly is on the path towards
neutralization far from it but that
something has fundamentally changed as
you can see from my data there are a
non-coincidental number of reports for
aquariums marine biologists and private
owners describing erratic and otherwise
abnormal behavior coinciding with the
incident of 0912 1992 it occurred
globally and lasted for approximately
three and a half minutes according to
observers the marine biology Department
can back me up on this as their own
specimens created rhythmic patterns with
their appendages all identical despite
being completely isolated from each
other and all seem transfixed with a
specific Direction regardless of their
current position they all faced towards
scp-4246-3's location as if it were some
kind of Mecca in recent years many new
discoveries have been made regarding
their intelligence they've always been
clever creatures more clever than they
had any right being considering their
short life spans and a social behavior
reports of tool use even degrees of
socialization and cooperation are
growing increasingly common I initially
dismissed this as a consequence of
improving research that such Behavior
has always been and that we are merely
recording it for the first time it would
have certainly been the simplest
explanation but it doesn't hold against
the overwhelming evidence this sudden
Divergence isn't limited to the
psychological as physiological changes
are being reported as well mutants have
been discovered altered across species
by genes shared through common ancestry
they are growing larger stronger and
even more alien thankfully these changes
aren't occurring simultaneously as these
mutants remain relatively rare and are
usually misidentified my hypothesis
explains many of our unanswered
questions why haven't paleontologists
discovered evidence of this race because
the fossil record is biased against
soft-bodied invertebrates what other
fully aquatic creatures would have had
the brains and physical ability to
manipulate tools a fish might be able to
use a twig with its mouth or a
crustacean could grip something with its
pincer but neither would have the
necessary dexterity to construct the
basic tools that would lead to the
development of civilization and
cetaceans are off the table mammals
wouldn't have even existed yet it all
seems so obvious now I don't believe
that their current state was forced on
them they had to change lest something
terrible would be drawn to this world
some inconceivable threat that took
insult to their intelligence be simple
and without light or the Beast will find
us they could have fled this Dimension
but instead chose the darkness of a long
sleep letting their minds and bodies
atrophy is nature erased nearly every
trace of their civilization
perhaps they couldn't bear to leave a
world they Steward it for so long I fear
they won't take kindly to our
destructive mismanagement of the planet
since their absence
scp-4246-4 has awaited them this entire
time and something we did convinced it
to proceed with its primary purpose as
Beyond us as they were the tethians
weren't gods they were cephalopods Dr
Freeman
okay I think that about does it for
today
thank you all for listening if indeed
you still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to
big sip
zargura
oh crop guy
the Morrigan
James Saba
Desiree 420
that loser
heroin sick
fire of prime
Andy versus the world
Spencer are doing
rubbish bin 69
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
worthy fire
zazapan
Lam k
agnar
alatreon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
and Lyndon B Johnson
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you